[Musique]
après les pizzas Buitoni les œufs Kinder
et les fromages Lactalis est autour des
baguettes Lidl d'être au coeur d'une
polémique sanitaire quelle attitude
comptez-vous adopter vis-à-vis de ces
marques en plein scandale sanitaire dans
un communiqué diffusé vendredi Lidl a dû
rappeler toutes ses baguettes céréales
rustiques vendu en France entre le 3 et
le 13 mai 2022 en raison du risque de
blessure et défaire indésirables suite à
l'ingestion de ce produit par précaution
il est recommandé aux personnes qui
détiendraient des produits appartenant
au lot d'écrit de ne pas les consommer
en cause la possible présence de métal
dans ce type de baguette une précision
apportée par Lidl qui demande à tous les
consommateurs en possession de ce
produit de le ramener en magasin alors
les baguettes de pain vendues par
l'ancienne Lidl rappeler car elles
peuvent contenir du métal faites-vous
toujours confiance aux grandes surfaces
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'agroalimentaire va être obligé de
tirer les coups et bien sûr de baisser
les prix parce que malheureusement
effectivement des gens au disent du mois
ils n'ont plus d'argent donc les donc
les l'industrie agroalimentaire va
s'aligner pour essayer de baisser les
prix plus il y aura du risque sanitaire
et là non je dois d'accord c'est pas le
respect sanitaire tu peux le surveiller
en contrôlant un maximum la société en
contrôlant un maximum d'entreprises
c'est pas le risque sanitaire c'est
surtout comment tu vas fabriquer ton
produit si tu vas chercher des graines
de chez Padou qui font 4000 km avant
d'arriver là il y a des fenêtres la
ferraille dedans oui c'était pas
l'hygiène et que ce soit même une grande
marque ou une petite marque l'hygiène
c'est déjà c'est la grande marque elle
déconne c'est pas parce que tu l'as payé
cher que tu vas pas être hygiène pour
l'hygiène notamment parce que justement
il réduisent les coûts ils réduisent le
temps le temps d'inspection et réduit
tout ça
comment vous vous sentez vous quand vous
allez faire vos courses
je me suis pas posé de questions et j'ai
voilà j'ai déambulé dans les rayons et
voilà j'ai pris ce qu'il fallait et puis
ça sera moi et ma chance les gars on a
pas le choix tu veux qu'on fasse comment
vous allez dans les rayons Cyril ah bien
sûr les rayons du supermarché ouais
faites vos courses bah oui
super marché
partout je vais aller chez Lidl je peux
aller chez Intermarché ça dans les
Mousquetaires je
m'en fous de mousquetaires donc voilà
donc je vois pas pourquoi je n'irai pas
et bien sûr d'autres grands marques je
vais chez mon ami en bas voilà
merveilleusement bien c'est Fauchon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes une star internationale et
pourquoi vous restez simple bravo Siri
chef du coup à combien est le prix de la
baguette la baguette ça dépend laquelle
10,80
moi j'aime bien les banettes oui alors
il y avait déjà 6 mois bordel
vous mangez pas de pain en faites
attention la prochaine fois qu'on vous
demande le prix de la baguette tu dis tu
vois ça c'est vraiment une phrase du mec
qui connaît pas parce que la baguette
c'est le produit qui varie le plus tu
peux trouver une baguette à 50 centimes
comme tu peux trouver une baguette à
1,40 donc ça c'est le mec qui te dit ça
tu dis à la raison
je défends je déforme monsieur
vous allez voir vous allez prendre une
fougasse dans la gueule
non mais c'est nul la baguette pas un
exemple il y avait une dame c'était dans
un autre supermarché qui avait trouvé
une vis dans sa baguette du métal et là
on pense que c'est une pièce métallique
qui se serait cassée dans la chaîne de
production donc ils vont enquêter
sûrement l'usure parce que c'est fou
quoi c'est une fois de plus voilà
l'usure voilà l'usure manque de
rénovation manque d'entretien voilà j'ai
un problème avec une grande marque il
fait mes courses en grande distribution
et on a trouvé un bout dedans parce que
la mienne c'est vous qui avez fait ça
bien sûr c'est votre main c'est votre
maman
alors là c'est la dent de quelqu'un
malade
mais je sais pas je suis rentré à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez arrêtez vous me gênez vous me
gênez oui alors donc je rentre à la
maison et là les enfants sont là en
panique les enfants
Daniel et voilà très beau et en fait ils
étaient vraiment mais sous le choc ils
étaient en panique et c'est le fils donc
qui a trouvé donc ce morceau dedans dans
une canette d'un soda dont c'est
incroyable au départ moi j'ai tout de
suite cru que c'était comme il a il a 14
ans je me suis dit c'est peut-être un
morceau dedans à lui après tout dans de
lait je sais pas un morceau comme ça
pour vérifier
et en fait le dentiste nous a dit que
c'était pas du tout à lui c'était pas un
morceau danse c'était pas quelque chose
ça sort n'avait pas bu dans la canette
et donc du coup bah j'étais vraiment
très choquée eux étaient carrément
dégoûté et en panique donc du coup j'ai
écrit au service
[Rires]
je te dis l'histoire moi j'ai un pote un
jour je vous jure que l'histoire est
vrai je vous jure qu'il soit arrivé il
m'a raconté qui s'est réveillé la nuit
il a entendu du bruit il y avait un rat
[ __ ]
il était [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils vont parler
aux toilettes il remonte et j'ai rien
dit ça va il s'est retrouvé face à face
avec un lac était comme astre mouillé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire est vraie histoire est vraie
la clope au bec
c'est pas une base c'est pour ça que je
le dis il faut toujours fermer les
cuvettes qu'on vous dormez je vous jure
que c'est vrai parce que les rats
arrivent comme ça moi j'ai toujours peur
quand je suis aux toilettes
tu imagines tu arrives quand Max je me
suis fait mordre l'oignon
pourquoi il viendrait vous mordre mais
tu crois quoi parce que il sait pas où
il est tu vois qu'il connaitre mon cul
tu prends vraiment
il arrive ça il sort comme ça la
totalité et toi tu te retrouves ah oui
mais c'est pas où il est sorti ou pas
il sort tu te remets mais c'est comme
c'est comme toi tu sors du micro-ondes
mais c'est un petit conseil donc fermer
toujours la la la la cuvette merci moi
je le fais tout le temps non mais tu as
raison maman
c'est un petit conseil pratique pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent
on va passer tout de suite au dos du
jour on va voter le sujet
au Service Client de la marque en
question on leur expliquant ce qui
s'était passé après avoir eu la
certitude que c'était pas un morceau
et ils m'ont répondu 5 jours après parce
qu'ils veulent tout savoir ils veulent
savoir où vous l'avez acheté quelle date
vous l'avez acheté contenant si ces
bouteilles si c'est canette si c'est pas
de pack de 6
ils veulent tout savoir la date et tout
ça et le ticket de caisse et tout ça bon
j'avais pas le ticket de caisse mais
bref et ils sont revenus vers moi cinq
jours après m'a dit c'est la dent de
Janine Payet
la jeune fille m'a laissé un message sur
mon répondeur et je dois la rappeler la
demain voilà c'est encore en cours
huit jours non à ce don là
toujours vider la canette dans un verre
parce que moi on voit ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur
comme ça directement donc il a eu le
choc quand il est mort sur la bouche
alors vous avez vu maintenant ce qu'ils
font ils mettent des petits papiers
maintenant tous les canettes de plus en
plus de marque pour pas voilà pour pas
comme ça et comme ça vous devez le
papier tu sais c'est très c'est très
mauvais de faire ça parce que les
canettes à son stockés ou dans un
entrepôt qui vous dit que dans
l'entrepôt le rat il a passé
vous vous ouvrez vos canettes vous
pouvez directement
nous avait dit ça Clément avait une
maladie exactement
[Rires]
c'est une grande marque de soda
le soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]